bay area homeowners are
being
asked to help to house
homeless residents
in the bay area of california in
northern california they are having
problems
uh homelessness
and the gov the government now to their
credit is no longer pretending that
they're functional remember that story
about the children who drive the
ambulances oh yeah you brought that to
my attention they didn't have anyone to
drive the ambulances so i forget where
this was but they just started enlisting
the help of i think like high school
kids
to just drive ambulances because they
couldn't find anyone else to do it and
again it was one of those feel-good
stories where they're like take a look
at this
we are so proud of our young boys and
girls
yeah in in rural sac it's harbor new
york jackets harbor new york covenant
local volunteer ambulance service local
high schools everyone has to require
training and pictures of people just
come up and ask me me and my friends
would be just baking out the ambulance
we'd just be getting so high in that
ambulance
let's watch this little segment
when people call for an ambulance in
sackett's harbor new york and the crew
shows up at their front door you're 12
almost everyone has the same reaction a
lot of people just come up and ask you
like wait how old are you right you're
the emt right when's the ambulance
coming so what do you say are you just
explaining to them we are the ambulance
these baby-faced first responders took
over the village's emergency medical
services not long after covet hit when
all the older ems volunteers either
couldn't or wouldn't do the job anymore
that's right that exodus was part of a
national trend that's rural america 35
of ambulance services are all volunteers
pay them and many maybe that's a bad
model 69
say they're struggling that's a horrible
model huh fortunately 40 percent of
people coming to get you are
doing it because they want to
pause in new york state so weird is that
a weird model 30 35
of ambulance workers in rural america
are volunteers
35 of people that are coming to get you
in your moment of need are doing it
because they feel like it
i mean
is that a problem
but now we got kids doing it so in the
great spirit of this because i think
this is great i think it's good everyone
pitch in
get in there and do it right
get in there and do it
get can you imagine being a young kid
well i was a piece of [ __ ] you know we
love drugs and
just being on long island being in an
ambulance being high
somebody called oh [ __ ] dude we got to
get this woman putting the siren on
so in san jose california as the bay
area continues to struggle under the
weight of its homelessness crisis
uh officials and non-profits are asking
local residents to do more than hand out
meals or donate spare change
i like that already hey
because no one's doing that either no
one's handing out meals so i like that
they're saying you got to do more than
this and people go who's doing that
handing out meals
they're asking them to open up their
homes nearly 30 000 people are unhoused
in the five-county bay area and there
isn't nearly enough room in the region's
existing affordable housing developments
to fill the gaps
service providers increasingly are
recruiting private landlords to take in
homeless tenants
some property owners are renting out
entire units in exchange for agreements
that the government or a non-profit will
cover the rent others are offering up a
spare bedroom fund in their homes
sometimes in exchange for a small
stipend sometimes as a purely or as a
purely charitable
act
now
how does this work
because i this is a very interesting
idea
you have a spare bedroom
and you bring in someone that may be
addicted to drugs or emotionally
unstable
and by the way
it's america so members of your
household already
may be addicted to drugs and emotionally
unstable you may be adding another
person
because that's what a lot of teenagers
are right now right
you have an emotionally unstable a drug
addict in the home and now you're
bringing in a buddy
you're bringing in a buddy
it's uh harry and the hendersons it's
like it's bringing in a fun
you know it's down and down beverly
hills watch the movie with nick nolte
it's been [ __ ] brilliant
quote here recruiting landlords is a
challenge for the homecoming project
which houses formerly incarcerated
people a group that's often stigmatized
using donations a non-profit pace hosts
in alameda and contra costa counties 30
a day to house someone in a spare
bedroom for six months
each former inmate is matched with a
case manager to help them find a job and
save money for a permanent home sex
offenders aren't eligible now let's get
one thing straight
i am very much for people turning your
lives around
and not being stigmatized
especially with non-violent drug charges
right
i don't think people should carry these
things for the rest of their life i
don't think it should prevent them from
working
and i do think that they need a place to
stay i do though think it is quite
hilarious
that with all the money that the
government of california takes in
the only option they have is to go to
citizens and go do you have a room
that's the only option
after the billions of
tax dollars that flow into the state
of california the only thing you can do
is say hey do you guys got any rooms
zach stein
zach stein and his wife volunteered with
say by the way remember there was a
homeless there was a guy in beverly wood
who worked with the homeless and i'm not
dissuading anyone from working with the
homeless by just telling you this
factual story
there was a guy in beverly wood who
worked with the homeless a homeless guy
followed him home
and stabbed him to death i think it was
brentwood maybe let me see
i believe it was in beverly wood but it
doesn't really matter people are
listening to this from some dungeon in
wisconsin they don't understand what
we're talking about we're talking about
beverly hills piglets
homeless man uh arrested for murder at
brentwood and camp well you were right
same difference
so
that was that i think that was a
different one but but my point is this
my point is this
you got to have cojones
to work with people that may kill you
right
zack stein and his wife volunteered with
safe time opening up their spare bedroom
in albany to a struggling young woman
for three months in some ways it was
really weird having a stranger there
stein said
but
the experience seemed to make a big
difference in the woman's life
start this was one of the andrew cuomo's
mistresses they had uh they housed
stein and his wife recently had a baby
and hope to continue hosting once they
get settled as parents well that seems
insane but they were able to buy their
house because they inherited money and
they want to share that good luck with
those less fortunate well that's the
beginning of a fun movie
i mean here's the deal there's a lot of
people that are down on their luck that
need help there's also a lot of people
that have real
real problems with mental illness and
drug addiction and the idea that you
would bring them into your house uh and
put your family and children at risk
seems insane to anybody and i know this
is one of those ideas that like 10
people write about on twitter and they
make it sound like it's a great idea but
human beings recoil from this
it's like you know the reason why the
democrats have lost a narrative on truly
everything right now is because the
democrats issues that have always made
sense to people or like the meat and
potatoes like yeah people shouldn't go
bankrupt when they get in a car accident
people do need health care people should
have a retirement right people believe
in those things but when you start
getting to this extreme
of the left where they go why don't you
why don't you hey how about you open
your house
haven't you got a room
because these are millionaires
why not put them in gavin newton how big
is that how big is gavin newsom's winery
can't they all go work on gavin newsom's
winery
i'm not saying you shouldn't be
charitable when you can but there's a
lot of this that screams a horrible idea
because you are not trained to deal with
people that are experiencing psychosis
you're not trained to deal with that
and it's america so there's already
people in your house with psychosis
this ain't new there's nothing new here
you're adding another nut
to a bag of nuts probably
talk to anyone now someone's lost it
anybody you talk to there's someone in
the house who's gone completely insane
so you're bringing in someone else and
that could be a real big problem
i just you know
i'll bring him in my house but you got
to do what i say i'll program them to
kill
if i if i adopt a homeless person can i
program them to kill
truly
if i bring if i sign up in this program
save time
can i get i want to get a [ __ ]
person in there that we can mk ultra to
do whatever we want
nothing truly violent
just like throwing a loaf of bread in a
politician
some funny
[ __ ]
good bits
good goofs
can we bring in a homeless person and
teach them how to do some goofs
well if you want to if you wanna open
your home to them i i
commend you
i'm not saying it's a bad idea
it's not a great idea